[Music]
fantastic so I'm gonna start a new
series and it's got to be weekly and I'm
gonna do something that I told myself I
wasn't gonna do but yeah I'm gonna do it
I'll explain why I'll do it and then
I'll just start doing it I had told
myself that I was going to not
habitually do more than one Doctor Who
video a week around here sunday is
Doctor Who that's that's what I do and I
never wanted to become a doctor who
channel and even though I know I'm
fairly well known for being that kind of
I didn't want that to become the focus
so much so that anytime I talked about
something else people were like why is
he talking about other stuff but there's
something that I feel I need to do and
to try and fit this into one Doctor Who
video a week scheduled along with the
other stuff that I want to do on Doctor
Who yeah it's not gonna work so until I
get caught up Wednesday is going to be
overdue Doctor Who review day that just
rolls off the tongue doesn't it and what
I mean by that is I only started doing
video reviews of Doctor Who episodes
starting with day of the doctor and that
means that all of Eccleston's run all of
tenants run except for waters of Mars I
actually did do a review of that
specifically and all of Smith's run
except for day and time of the doctor I
don't have reviews up for so I want to
correct that and I'm gonna have it be
Wednesdays and I'm gonna have it be one
a week until I'm caught up but I have
reviews for all the Doctor Who episodes
up so people can see and all that stuff
so where
further ado let's begin appropriately
enough at the beginning and that means
we're gonna take a look at series 1
episode 1 rows so there are some things
about this episode that I love and I can
pretty much sum it up in two words
Christopher Eccleston he I fell in love
with him I think by I'd say 30 seconds
since his introduction into it like
right off the bat he he runs into Rose
you know he helps her escape from Autons
which is a phone call back is there
there are classic who villain they were
in the first color Doctor Who story so
that's kind of cool and you know he runs
with her and he kind of you know banters
with her a bit and then you know he
hurries her out of the building
I'm through this back alley and I can
tell you the moment that I fell in love
with Christopher Eccleston his doctor
and it was when he putt he shoes are off
closes the door opens the door again
pops his head back out and goes I'm the
doctor by the way what's your name
she says Rose Tyler nice to meet you
rose run for your life and he's holding
a bomb the grin on his face the joy in
what he's doing I and especially as
we've since gotten the greater context
for what the doctor has been through in
his own recent past up to that point it
just makes this amazing because you
realize he's just so excited to just be
saving a planet again you know just
dealing with a low-level threat against
something that he can actually help
because he's been dealing with time war
for who knows how long
but like it's just a little thing all
right I can help this this is great
that energy and yet there are also
moments of the sadness when he takes
roses hands and said I can feel the turn
of the earth were falling through space
and I can feel it you get those hints of
melancholy with him that is gonna
underscore his time in the park and I
love that too and he he hooked me so
early he was fantastic he's you know
it's the word he uses it's a great word
for his performance pheromone are the
other stuff here I'm a little bit iffy
on the Autons themselves I think I like
is that it's a neat little callback so
they're fine they're functional
it's and I think that was that's what
you kind of have to go with for your
first episode villain you don't want to
break out the huge guns right away you
kind of want to you know have it's nice
to have like villains who are
recognizable for old-time fans but also
ones that aren't gonna require a ton of
explanation or and don't have a ton of
depth so you don't need to sit there
you're having four long conversations
with these things or whatever else cuz
you know we're in a new format now we're
at a 45 minute format so I think the
Autons allow us to sort of keep things
moving while getting a little bit of
Doctor Who iconography into things so I
they work pretty well
Rose rose grew on me over time her
initial introduction in this I was like
she's fine she seemed okay I didn't like
Jackie initially I'm not I'm not gonna
lie and again I I found things to like
about her later but you know she was
just kind of there and like yeah okay
you know slightly lonely mother probably
used to party in her youth okay yeah and
Mickey Mickey was almost kind of a non
presence in this I will say this however
I hate the sentient garbage bin
and plastic Mickey I hate both those
things cuz that's an example of you know
to call back to a video I did Oh a
couple weeks maybe a month ago
that's where dr. crosses the line of too
silly
doctor who can be silly I mean the
Autons themselves are kind of silly if
you know their killer store mannequins
basically but when you have a burping
trashcan and when you have Mickey
looking this obviously so unlike himself
and Rose not noticing for as long as she
does it feels like Saturday morning
cartoon it's the wrong kind of silly
it's it's it's taking something that
should be frightening her boyfriend
being replaced and she doesn't know
about it and making it ridiculous and
that doesn't work for me
like very much at all I also think I the
resolution of this episode is also not
great in my mind there's the something
about the doctor having I mean I know he
says he wasn't gonna use it but just
having what is effectively a species
specific poison in his pocket I'm kind
of like doesn't seem like the most
doctor thing in the world and Rose just
kind of swinging in feels a little bit
contrived what I will say is despite the
fact that Rose herself I don't love her
off the bat she does have a good rapport
and good chemistry with Eccleston which
is vital because you know that there are
times that there are characters who I
may not like in a vacuum but who play
well off of the other characters that
they're involved in I do think that is a
case here with with Rose but overall the
highlight of this episode unquestionably
is the doctor himself
Eccleston just sells the heck
out of this part and and the music
honestly does a good job too because we
have the doctor's theme marigolds the
doctors theme that slow kind of mournful
choral piece which is a great underscore
for especially this particular
regeneration of the doctor so while it's
not the best start in the world the
things that it needed to nail it does
it's just some of the additional stuff
as it's going along as it's like that
didn't quite mmm but it got the doctor
and that is the most important thing he
got him right off the bat he is
wonderful and he's sweet and he's kind
of funny and he's you just you want to
travel with it and that's what the
doctor should be so those are my
thoughts on Rose so yeah this'll be
weekly so hope people are interested in
my takes on these old episodes people
indicated that they would I asked about
this a while back people seemed fairly
enticed by the idea but yeah I got a lot
to get through so that's what it'll be
oh one last note people might note this
is taking up the weekly slots that have
been taken by my reviews of inside
number nine I'm I really don't think I'm
gonna do video reviews for that again
III did enjoy the show but I mean look
I'll be completely honest those videos
were like the only things I've put up in
the last year they couldn't even crack a
thousand views like I know some people
like them but if I do any more reviews
of inside number nine I might toss them
off in a podcast as opposed to doing
them as video form and if I do I'll like
I'll mention that in in the community
section or something so that the people
who liked my reviews of those can can
can find them that's a maybe right now I
need to figure out what I'm gonna what
I'm gonna get back to the show now that
I finished off series one I'm rambling
at this point in any case rose series 1
episode 1 Christopher Eccleston is first
go as the doctor what did you think
about it whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it there's a bunch of buttons
and links and stuff including to my
patreon and check them out if you're
interested and remember folks you or the
council I just run the meetings and
until next time this council is
adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]